why shave my head is because I recognize
what goes viral because I've seen snico
do it because Andrew Tate was bald or
maybe because I'm so sick of this
current pattern that I need something as
drastic as shaving my head to throw me
on a different path
I don't know I didn't even tell anyone I
was making this video
I grabbed the same razor I shaved my
balls with and I said [__] it I'm going
bald so what are we going to talk about
in this video are we going to talk about
how you're wasting time right now
watching YouTube videos about the
political and economics state of the
world or maybe how batteries are glued
into our phone so they can enslave our
minds and always listen to us
joking today we're here to talk about
that last Point our minds aren't ours
anymore we see words on the screen we're
fed thoughts then those new thoughts are
our beliefs nobody's original anymore
you can look at anyone's social media
and be able to tell basically all of
their beliefs pronouns in the bio you
hate Trump your pro-abortion your triple
jab your pro-trans and Tate deserves to
rot in jail fishing picture you love
Trump you hate liberals you love guns
and Biden's ruin in this country it's
funny that's only one piece to the
social media facade and it's not even
the worst part every time we come up on
any mental roadblock we're instant to
open Instagram to distract us from what
we need to do to get to where we want to
be you do it he does it we all [__]
do it from Instagram it goes to
brainlessly scrolling through stories to
Twitter to Snapchat and then back to
Instagram without a single thought
firing in your brain I'm sure you
noticed how you have all your best ideas
when you're in the shower or right
before you go to bed
maybe it's because that's literally the
only chance you give your brain to think
rather than be fed the next time you
open Instagram think what was the last
thing that went through your head before
clicking on I can guarantee it was a
hard thought you didn't want to think
through and solve or put your brain into
a creative process whether it's a hard
business dot for you fellow online money
people a homework problem you don't feel
like solving or maybe you're just in a
social situation where there's two
seconds of awkwardness so you all
instantly go to your phones
these mechanisms are here to enslave our
brains kill the will to critically think
or move through our thoughts and nobody
gives a [__] we keep scrolling consuming
and posting just for the validation of
double Taps from sleeping Minds
the next crack in the facade social
media jealousy scrolling on Tick Tock in
bed at night looking at 10 out of 10s
thinking why not me but really why me
everything is an illusion
whenever you see something in the moment
you think you'd kill to get there's
someone else who's tired of the same
[__] even us we drink water eat food
have the freedom to watch YouTube videos
all day yet we still find [__] to
complain about in our heads and who
knows how this girl even is I've been in
the shoes of the guy with the 10 out of
10 but then I realize she's a [__]
hoe and I ghost her am I allowed to say
that right now or is society in the face
where I get canceled if I call a girl a
[__] hoe meanwhile her DMS are
flooded with blue checks and horny dudes
despite this we still look at the girls
on Instagram and think my God it would
be amazing to have a girl like that with
that I'm done sometimes you get pushed
to the point of having a Brad Pitt in
your head telling you to do crazy [__]
and it seems like the only logical
solution sometimes I feel like the only
one trying to escape the Mind Trap and
retain my Consciousness I'm on this
Earth for a mission I can't settle for
anything less than utter greatness
upgrading my character to 99 overall at
the end of the day true hell is the
person you are meeting the person you
could have been and all of you can be
somebody but your minds aren't yours
anymore
wake up
my mind telling me no
no but my body
my body telling me yeah
I got a haircut